[Music]
so
it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning children in england are heading
back to school and with their return
come big questions to be answered what
effects will the mixing of students have
on the nation's coronavirus figures
will the government's catch-up program
actually get people's learning back on
track after the severe disruption caused
by the pandemic the education secretary
gavin williamson joins us in the studio
in just a few minutes time uh but also
on the program we'll be discussing this
the perilous situation for female judges
in afghanistan at half past seven i'll
be speaking to one woman who escaped the
taliban
and one who's still fearing for her life
inside the country
also ahead
how locked down got us up and moving up
some of us a quarter tonight legendary
long distance runner paula radcliffe
will be joining us to discuss the
evidence that the pandemic has increased
activity levels
it's thursday 2nd of september
testing the recovery unions warn that
covert cases could rise as pupils return
to school in england and where
all my gcse work so far has kind of had
this disruption that it'd be nice to
kind of just go through
go through you know at least a term or
whatever without any kind of isolation
the foreign secretary heads to doha for
talks with qatari leaders on how to help
british nationals still trying to leave
afghanistan
the afghan refugee who made it to the
very top of women's football but hasn't
changed her opinion the taliban regime
they're the wolves that are you know
disguised themselves and she's right now
and then the true call is going to come
true
a state of emergency is declared in new
york as flash floods and heavy rain hit
the city
dripping in gold the swimmer turned
cyclist dame sarah story becomes great
britain's most successful paralympian
ever
and as for the weather mild and cloudy
for most with the best of the sunshine
in scotland
[Music]
morning all people start to return to
classrooms in england and wales this
morning and what could prove a big test
for two key government policies in
england pupils will now be able to mix
with other years other year groups face
coverings are optional and contacts of a
positive case will no longer have to
isolate automatically these relaxed
measures have led unions to warn that
covert 19 infections could rise
meanwhile the government is hoping that
six million pupils will benefit from its
catch-up support designed to make up for
the disruption caused by the pandemic
laura bundik has our first report
they've brought them in early for
lateral flows but there's a much bigger
test ahead can schools keep covid under
control students at the charter school
in south london hope so all my gcse work
so far has kind of had this disruption
that it'd be nice to kind of just go
through
go through you know at least a term or
whatever without any kind of isolation
we've been in and out of lockdowns for
the past two years and obviously it's
quite important since we're in year 11.
i'll be able to commute with the
teachers more easily they'll be able to
get across to me more easily face to
face contact i think that's better than
online walk through the corridors and
all restrictions are now removed it's a
really exciting moment the students are
coming back
it's going to be a normal opportunity
for them they're going to be able to go
around the entire school bubbles are
gone as are face masks and whole class
isolations if everything goes right then
we will we
will keep the school open we will keep
it running and we will continue to have
a good learning experience for our
students
we did it last year we had very few
outbreaks and problems last year here
they hope routine testing will help and
students will receive regular reminders
when children are backing classrooms
it's widely expected cases will rise how
much and for how long isn't known but
one thing certain a balance this term
will have to be struck for students
between the risk of the virus and the
risk of more disruption to learning
unions warn more must be done to keep
kids in classrooms the measures we need
in place to stop cases spreading so that
children don't miss school are real
improvements in ventilation in air
filtration possibly in mask wearing we'd
like to see the prime minister putting
out a call for secondary students to
test themselves twice a week with the
lft test you just need to do five
circles in each nostril okay it will be
a testing new term the challenge now
losing restrictions and keeping schools
open laura bundock sky news in south
london
uh and as mentioned we are hoping to be
speaking to the education secretary
gavin williamson in just a few minutes
time for some face-to-face learning
today we are for that uh but still to
come on the program aside from the
education secretary
[Music]
we'll be speaking uh to treat
five minutes past day we'll be speaking
to preet girl livers shadow
international development secretary to
see what she thinks the foreign
secretary can achieve in qatar
at 20 past dates i'll be speaking to the
chief inspector inspector of ofsted
about students returning to schools in
england and wales
[Music]
i don't have power state so christopher
mayer will be here uh talking about
global terror threats following the
taliban's takeover of afghanistan
but as we wait for the education
secretary let's take a look at a few of
the day's other main stories now
and uh well first let's start with the
latest coronavirus data for the uk shall
we there have been
a further 35
693 new cases of coronavirus reported in
the latest 24-hour period
a further 207 people
died after contracting kovid
this number is likely to include some
delayed reporting due to the bank
holiday it takes the total number of
people who've died within 28 days of a
positive test
to 132
742.
breaking news this morning a state of
emergency has been declared in new york
city and new jersey
uh dramatic pictures but in a tweet the
mayor of the city bill de blasio
want people uh to stay inside to avoid
the flash floods and heavy rain he asked
new yorkers to stay off the streets and
to let first responders and emergency
services get their work done
flooding has been recorded across the
city including these images of a subway
station being overcome by water and
there's been further reports of flash
flooding in washington dc and pittsburgh
as well as the aftermath from tornadoes
in new jersey and maryland
i'm very pleased to say that the
education secretary gavin borenson is
here with us in the studio very good as
i mentioned good to have some
face-to-face learning for once between
the two of us i think we've all been
craving it we have indeed you know it's
back to normality as much as possible
well that is an appropriate place for
where we should start then of course you
will want to talk i'm sure about the
tutoring that you're that you're
announcing today but in terms of people
getting back to school today
how confident are we we hit term running
it's starting as we mean to go on that
we will not see as we perhaps edge into
the winter months some form of reversal
well we're very confident but i mean i
think you'd probably want to join us
today sort of wishing all those children
maybe going to school for the first time
a little bit of excitement a little bit
of nervousness that they're feeling
those children going on to secondary
school or just moving up a year wishing
them the very best and what we wanted to
do is to get that school experience
back to that sort of normal pre-pandemic
sort of sense as before i think that's
the right thing to do you know we've
been over the summer we've been enjoying
life back as normal going to pubs going
to sporting venues it's really important
that
children are getting that normal
experience to boot so how are we going
to ensure that that normal experience
continues testing
is clearly going to be a big part of
that testing is a vital part of that and
that's why we're rolling out testing for
all secondary school pupils you're
seeing uh you know seeing over the next
couple of weeks you'll see somewhere in
the region of uh nine million tests uh
plus done in terms of uh children and
we're wanting to capture the virus there
but of course we do have a contingency
framework
in place if there's areas of particular
need that we do have to take further
action but when you say contingency
framework what do you mean because
people will hear that and they will
assume back to bubbles back to classes
perhaps whole year groups being told to
go home yeah so that's what we are
absolutely clear that we want to avoid
that's why we've made the changes that
we have we want children to be in the
classroom yes of course if a child has
covered they'll have to self-isolate
test and trace will contact those who've
been in contact with them and they'll
advise them to have a pcr test but
actually those children will able to
continue to go to school they're able to
continue to be in the classroom unless
they test positive but can we just be
absolutely clear there is an expectation
isn't there that we are going to see
covert cases rise and rise significantly
as a result of face-to-face learning
again just as we have seen in scotland
uh we are having to strike a sensible
balance a sensible balance to making
sure that children get the very best
education we aren't expecting corporate
cases to rise we must be
but this is why you know we're doing the
mass testing in schools because we want
to identify those cases and as i say
you're going to see
9 million plus tests carried out over
the next few weeks
really trying to spot those covered
cases before they go into school in
terms of the children that are getting
back to school today children young
adults of course getting back into
school today it will be markedly
different from the conditions that they
left the other side of the term end to
bubbles the end to the kind of the
yearly exclusion of whole years face
masks certainly not being mandated in
schools i mean jeff barton and from the
association of school and college
leaders
suggested it feels a little like a case
of hitting hope on the part of the
government why did we not continue with
some of those mitigations well we have
continued with uh sort of key elements
of mitigations including the testing but
there's a big difference between schools
returning uh this september compared to
when schools returned last september uh
and in march and the key difference is
that
the british population everyone who's of
uh
every adult has been offered not just
one job but two and of course vaccines
are the thing that have been the game
changer that's the reason that we've
been able to lift national restrictions
but for me children getting a normal
education experience as it was
pre-pandemic is so vital because we've
got to put them first above all of us
understand that but in terms of the
vaccination program the jcvi
are dragging their heels on making an
announcement about a potential booster
program the jcvi similarly appear to be
dragging their heels and telling us what
the advice is for for for those under
16. is it perhaps the moment for the the
joint committee on vaccination and
immunizations to get a bit of a rigol on
and come to a decision on some of these
things well i think speaking as a parent
myself i think parents would find this
incredibly reassuring to know that they
had a choice as to whether their child
uh would be vaccinated or not and i
really listen there is a big question
though isn't there currently as to
whether or not we allocate our vaccine
resources directly to a booster program
which we would need to get started on
immediately or we address it to younger
children to young adults i think so well
we've got the capacity to be able to
deliver vaccinations for children as
well as deliver a booster program so
it's not an either or it's a situation
about making sure that we combat this
virus as best as possible and we're
ready if we get the
the get go from jcvi we're ready to uh
the nhs which has been so successful in
rolling out this program of vaccination
is ready to go into schools and deliver
that vaccination program for children
sorry deliver the point but but i i
would like to hear the words from you
that you're expecting a rise and
potentially a significant rise in covert
infections because of children getting
together again the fact is the data
shows that as many as one in seven
children and young people who catch
covert could have the symptoms of long
covered for months after this is a
largely unvaccinated cadre this is a
largely unvaccinated class so i think
there is a responsibility on people who
are telling children to get back into
school to accept the fact that some of
them
will as a result develop long covert
so this is why we're doing the testing
program when we're encouraging you know
children to take part in it parents and
of course
teachers and support staff themselves
because this is how we can catch covid
and we've seen over 70 million tests
delivered in terms of schools and
colleges
over the last few months and actually
this is a way of rooting out covid and
you did see it was successful uh in
terms of identifying covid cases and we
believe by successful some would say
well but but what we are trying to do is
we're trying to strike that constant
sensible balance of actually
giving children as normal experience in
the classroom as possible but also
recognizing we're still dealing with a
global pandemic i suppose then people
would question why more has not been
more action is not being done in terms
of ventilation in schools we have known
since midway last year perhaps even
earlier than that that you know this was
aerosol this was airborne
and working in confined circumstances
like this studio in a classroom you
needed decent ventilation the only
action that has been taken so far is the
announcement that co2 detectors will be
sent out so we'll be able to identify
where ventilation is needed in schools
but we're not providing the money to
provide the ventilation so so we it's a
whole package of measures that we've
been doing and and depending on where
we've been in the pandemics sort of
making the judgment as to what type of
contingency and support measures are
there uh you're right to point out the
fact that we're rolling out the co2
monitors so they can identify different
areas uh there's a whole set of when we
get the money for ventilation though i
mean that's what the schools are calling
it right now there's a whole set of
measures that they can undertake in
terms of actually sort of dealing with
some of those challenges but of course
the biggest way that we converting the
women you know the biggest thing that we
can actually do in terms of actually
helping schools get back to normal of
course has been the vaccination program
and the vaccination program is there to
give people the protection uh and the
confidence to go back to their normal
lives and that's the success of it
that's why uh unlike in march where we
had to have so many more restrictions as
children go back in september you know
they can have that normal school
experience again that we want for all
our children i don't want to stress
anyone going back into school on day one
about you know the prospect of exams
later on this year but they do need to
know how they will be judged on
on which way
their merits will be judged this year
when will do you think we'll have a
definitive answer as to what will happen
exam time next year i think that's a
really important issue that you raise
that's why
back in july before schools broke up for
summer we set out to schools and to all
that we're interested in it what that
process of assessment would look like
for
this academic year that we're just
entering uh we wanted to give people the
confidence of what they'd have we
obviously understandably have to do a
public consultation we've done that
public consultation and uh we we look
forward to very much confirming as to uh
the sort of the proposals that we've
been sort of uh putting forward
explaining to schools what that looks
like this is the side of the next kind
of you know the next fortnight's holiday
imminently uh very very imminently but
we've given schools a real sense and
real taste what it looks like what it'll
feel like uh so they can have a
confidence to plan i did want to ask you
about this and i don't want to rehash
the arguments that were made around the
time of the of of the exam results
coming up but we we know of course
from the results that we got seventy
percent of or of grades in the
independent sector were a or a star 40
in the state sector were a or a star a
huge gap between those who can pay for
their education and those who can't you
and i both went to comprehensive schools
you and i have both sat in rooms
opposite people who spent an awful lot
of money on their education perhaps even
around the cabinet table and have
thought where did all that money go you
are the one person in this conservative
government who could say this is
absolutely disgraceful that our killed
kids are being failed then if you have
enough money you can guarantee them a
better quality of life i just wonder
what your thoughts are on so what i the
thing that drives me so much in terms of
politics the reason why i wanted to
become an mp is because you want to make
a difference i think of so many of my
friends who i went to school with you
know a very normal comprehensive school
up in scarborough is actually making
sure that they have the right
opportunity and you want to close those
gaps this pandemic sadly has exacerbated
some of the differences in society and
we want to drive that change back and so
is the funding though i mean the
institute for fiscal studies has
said despite the government allocating
another seven billion pounds average
spending per pupil in 2022 23 will still
be about one to two percent lower in
real terms than two thousand nine
understand the past couple of years have
had an effect but we are still
dramatically underfunding the state
education system in this country aren't
we so what we've seen the last two years
since the prime minister came in he's
been able to
deliver record funding packages not just
last year but also into this year we're
going into a comprehensive spending
review uh it wouldn't surprise you as
being education secretary i'll probably
be asking for uh for more is probably
what people would always be expecting
but you know what we're wanting to see
is world-class schools it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter whether you take my
point where there's this disparity
between the independent sector and the
state sector at a time when schools are
just not getting the amount of money
that they need to get from the
government some of the blame for that
great disparity has to fall on you yeah
so this is why we've been raising the
funding that we have in terms of state
schools over the last two years it's a
mission that the prime minister and i
both share we want to make that uh
different we want to make the difference
for all those people that you know
you know the types of people that you
and i went to school with because they
were our friends it's what we what we
know it's the difference we want to make
that is uh you know our mission we've
been delivering that extra funding we
want to continue to deliver that funding
and we want to make that difference just
briefly i'm not going to ask you about
your a-level results you as a minister
know what it's like to be under pressure
from the papers from the broadcasters
from your back benches i just wonder on
the basis of what you saw from dominick
rabb yesterday
do you think his position is safe now
absolutely the prime minister has been
clear he has complete confidence in
the work that the foreign secretary has
been doing you're seeing dom going out
to
out to doha and qatar today in order to
be able to
make a difference in terms of leading
negotiations playing a global role to
make sure that those people who are
still in afghanistan that need safe
passage have that safe package passage
out of afghanistan so busy day for you
as indeed it is for plenty of kids up
and down the country we'll let you go
thanks very much
uh we had to mention there the foreign
secretary dominic rabb has flown to
qatar in an effort to negotiate the
government's attempt to get more british
nationals out from afghanistan our
correspondent sally locke joins us live
from doha sally just bring us up to date
with the latest do we know who he's
meeting with where he's meeting
yeah that's right dominic rad the
foreign secretary arrived in doha last
night we understand he'll be meeting
with qatari government leaders such as
the emir of qatar as well as the deputy
prime minister and the foreign minister
the foreign minister uh absolutely no
suggestion dominic rob will be meeting
with members of the taliban leadership
who of course have had their political
office here for years now but
the uk is in talks with the taliban
already now on the agenda we understand
to be priority number one evacuating
those remaining british nationals
from afghanistan and also ensuring safe
passage for any afghan citizens who are
still in the country who worked for the
british military in the last 20 years
that's number one on the agenda but they
also will be discussing the security and
humanitarian issues happening and
unfolding in afghanistan the threat of
isis k of course how they deal with that
in collaboration with the taliban but
also the unfolding humanitarian issues
such as the fact that the majority of
foreign aid has been frozen into
afghanistan that remains the case
afghanistan's economy is heavily reliant
on it many people still can't access
cash one in three afghans have no idea
where their next meal is coming from the
taliban yes is in control of the country
now wields the power but we don't know
who their government is yet and we have
no idea
what their plan is for running the
country i can tell you that qatari
officials and
turkish officials flew into kabul
airport yesterday technical teams to
look at getting the airport back up and
running we understand that they are
working on the radar system that's
encouraging news there's already a
runway there the infrastructure is there
if they get the radar system up and
running then we could see flights
resuming into kabul uh very soon but
there is a very uh sensitive issue of
security who's going to run that at the
airport uh the taliban want to so far
the turks and the qataris have said no
that is not going to happen stalemate
there but certainly some progress that
those technical teams are already in the
country and certainly progress that the
foreign secretary is here now in the
region attending talks as well
sally many thanks indeed
it's always nice we've got some good
news to bring you in the morning and
this is the best damn serious story has
become britain's most successful
paralympian ever winning her 17th gold
medal on a very successful morning for
gb's cyclist nbc reporter heather cox is
in tokyo and has this roundup of all the
action from day 10 of the paralympics
and indeed what we still have to look
forward to
some more historic moments happening
here today in tokyo in the woman's road
race dame sarah's story won her 17th
paralympic gold medal surpassing swimmer
mike kenny's previous record of 16 for
great britain story's teammate crystal
lane wright finished with the silver
making it the third time the two have
finished one two in these games
and the headline at track and field is
all about conditions we've seen rain the
past few days here in tokyo particularly
heavy at olympic stadium where athletes
have been slipping on the slick track
the rain is back again today and is
forecasted to continue into the night
where we'll see american daniel roman
chuck who narrowly captured gold in the
hundred meter go for a second gold in
the 800 an event in which he holds the
current world record
and tonight it's the women's semifinals
in wheelchair basketball as germany
faces off with the netherlands while
china takes on team usa who are looking
for their fifth paralympic gold the
united states is led by team captain
natalie schneider the 38 year old mother
of three who hopes to set the tone for
her young team
now let's focus just a little bit more
on the gb pad olympic team shanghai
matariki is in the newsroom and he'll be
sharing my excitement this morning not
least because of all the pun
opportunities that sarah's story's name
provides what a fantastic story for
example
morning nile a fantastic story indeed
overnight history was made as sarah
story became the greatest british
paralympian of all time winning her 17th
gold medal in that c45 road race passing
the swimmer mike kenny's mark which he
set in 1988 all those years ago it's her
third goal of these games and it wasn't
easy though the conditions in the race
were damp and rainy probably closer to
those she's seen in manchester as
opposed to those you normally get in a
summer in tokyo in the shadow of mount
fuji and with two laps to go she trailed
the race by 75 seconds before storming
clear winning seven seconds clear of her
teammate crystal lane wright who is also
part of paralympics gb and her journey
is not just one of success but
remarkable longevity if you remember
that she taking it back to 1992 when she
started her paralympic journey she was a
14 year old swimmer now as a 43 year old
she's the most decorated paralympian in
the history of our country so plenty to
celebrate i'm layered shanghai thanks
very much indeed
time to see how the weather is looking
as we nudge towards the weekend
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and for the next week while it will be
mainly dry with sunny spells developing
more widely but it will turn more
unsettled from sunday
mostly mild and quite cloudy at the
moment some hill fog and a few drizzly
outbreaks in the east but western parts
are clearer and rather chilly some mist
and fog patches in the countryside the
morning we'll see sunny spells
developing widely away from the north
sea coasts after a mainly grey start
with scotland once again having the best
of the sunshine fairly cool overall
especially near the eastern coasts
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
they say that two is always better than
one and that's definitely the case in
sri lanka right now
as twin elephants have been born twin
elephants for the first time in 80 years
oh
that's quite sweet the male calves are
born to 25 year old female surangi and
17 year old male pandu which is a bit of
a cougar at the pinnawala elephant
orphanage in the sri lankan hills
and who can fail to be cheered up by
that on a thursday morning
still to come after the break we will be
discussing the somewhat perilous
situation for female judges in
afghanistan we'll be speaking to one
woman who escaped the taliban one who
still fears for her life inside the
country
[Music]
[Music]
extremely excited and actually can't
quite believe um that one of my images
has been chosen um so i'm still
very you know feeling over the moon and
it's just very surreal for me so i was
really lucky to be in tanzania in the
serengeti during july and august of last
year
and this is a time when the wildebeest
migration is at its peak there are
millions of antelope species migrating
through the landscape and we just
happened to see this lioness as she
pounced upon a wildebeest and we drove
over re-angled the vehicle and this
female was
enjoying
a morning feast and unfortunately the
poor wildebeest was still alive
and as we drove the vehicle closer she
looked up at us and just gave us this
intense challenging stare she was almost
warning us away from her kill
and she just happened to look straight
down my camera lens and you can see her
face is just covered in this bright red
oxygenated blood i mean her kill was as
fresh as can be first and foremost i'm
actually a conservation biologist and i
started taking photos on the side
alongside my research and definitely the
more you're out there the more
opportunities you have to see these
incredible behaviors that you might not
necessarily see if you're only there for
a week or two and so absolutely it's a
combination of luck but also just
developing your skill and your eye as a
photographer
i feel like i've definitely come a long
way in the time that i've been using my
camera so
but yeah luck plays a critical role i
think
the best thing about photography is it
really is a universal language you know
you don't have to speak english to
understand what's going on in a photo um
i think it's just one of the best ways
to try and talk about the issues that
are going on in the natural world right
now
it's estimated that around 70 of our
coastlines are experiencing increased
erosion
[Music]
we start with a steel structure that we
put into the sea floor we then pass a
very small electrical current between
what we call an anode and the cathode
the structure itself is the cathode
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back hundreds of thousands of
pupils are returning to their classrooms
this week with experts predicting a
surge in covered 19 cases linked to
schools reopening a short while ago i
spoke to the education secretary gavin
williamson and pressed him on whether
the government expects cases to rise
over the coming weeks
we are having to strike a sensible
balance a sensible balance to making
sure that children get the very best
education we aren't expecting cases to
rise we must be
but this is why you know we're doing the
mass testing in schools because we want
to identify those cases and as i say
you're going to see
9 million plus tests carried out over
the next few weeks really trying to spot
those covid cases before they go into
school
in terms of the children they're getting
back to school today children young
adults of course getting back into
school today it will be markedly
different from the conditions that they
left the other side of the term end to
bubbles then to the kind of the yearly
exclusion of whole years face masks
certainly not being mandated in schools
i mean jeff barton and from the
association of school and college
leaders
suggested it feels a little like a case
of hitting hope on the part of the
government why did we not continue with
some of those mitigations well we have
continued with uh sort of key elements
of mitigations including for testing but
there's a big difference between schools
returning uh this september compared to
when schools returned last september uh
and in march and the key difference is
that
the british population everyone who's of
uh uh every adult has been offered not
just one jab but two and of course
vaccines are the thing that have been
the game changer that's the reason that
we've been able to lift national
restrictions but for me children getting
a normal education experience as it was
pre-pandemic is so vital because we've
got to put them first above all of
us uh let's have a chat with our
political correspondent tomorrow cohen
money tc i've got to say i'm i'm vaguely
surprised actually that despite the
pressing we pressed for longer than just
just that clip from the interview you
know the education secretary would not
concede that which everyone knows to be
the case if you open up the schools and
you have people mixing together indoors
and there will be a rise in covert cases
yes and that's what we've seen in
scotland where the schools opened two or
three weeks ago in the past week there's
been an 80 rise in cases that nicola
sturgeon has called extremely alarming
everyone is expecting a similar thing to
happen in schools in england and wales
now they're opening for many of them
today or the beginning of next week and
the education secretary was open about
the fact that things are in many
respects back to pre-pandemic there are
no bubbles in primary schools there are
no masks the parents can gather outside
the big difference he said is that in
secondary schools there will be testing
now that testing is not mandatory it is
encouraged that all children and
teachers do two lateral flow tests a
week and they hope that that will keep a
lid on the number of covered cases
because anyone who has any symptoms will
be sent home and anyone who's been in
contact them will will be tested more
regularly but still there is no
recognition from government that there
may be a very steep rise in cases and
although the education department say
they are doing contingency plans for
what might happen if there are very high
numbers of cases in a certain area he
gave very little away about what new
measures might be brought in
tomorrow for now thanks very much indeed
this is a fascinating story one of the
world's leading female footballers who
fled from her home in afghanistan has
told sky news that she doesn't believe
that the taliban have changed nadia
nadim grew up in a refugee camp after
her father was executed by the taliban
when she was just 11 years old since
then she's played for top clubs in both
europe and the united states this guy
sadia chaudhary was able to speak to her
she defied the odds to become a star in
global football but nadia nadim hoped
she'd be the only one that would have to
do that
the afghanistan she'd left behind was
changing her father's killers had been
ousted and girls could try and mimic her
moves on the football pitch
but last month all that changed
it's been heartbreaking to watch what's
happening in afghanistan right now
just because i felt we were over that
stage i was like in the you know back
in the history and it would not repeat
itself and i know what that means for
for the future of the country
what it means for
the
development
of
of the country what it means for the
women and the girls
after her father's death nadia and her
family fled first to pakistan and then
to europe she made denmark's national
team and last season as liga champion
with paris saint-germain she perhaps
gave thousands of young afghan girls the
belief they too
could rise to the top
how do you feel about young girls who
would have watched you playing football
and have dreams of playing football
of their own what would you say to them
now
that's a hard one i don't know what to
say to them because i know they don't
they're not gonna have the opportunity
to do so but i i wanna say that people
should try to keep their hopes up
even though that it really really looks
like a dark situation
many people are saying the taliban have
changed do you believe they've changed
um no i don't think so i think
they're the wolves that are you know uh
disguised themselves and shift right now
and then the true call is going to come
true my dad was
killed by the taliban
so i know what they stand for and what
their values are
today the country is once again
controlled by the group that killed her
father
a devastating reality for nadia i think
there's a lot of similarities i think
right now because it's a transition
and so they're kind of i still feel like
low-key holding them back but if you see
what's happening in the airports and
people trying to
hang on planes and falling out of skies
no one would react that way if
if you were not scared
nadia still remembers the fear that
drove her from her childhood home
chaos and horror just like today she
says and the feeling of being powerless
sadia chaudhary sky news
a remarkable woman uh elsewhere
cristiano ronaldo has broken the men's
international goal scoring record
after converting two late headers
portugal coming from a goal down to beat
the republic of ireland 2-1
in their world cup qualifier those goals
taking his tally to 111 international
goals smashing iran's ali dais record of
109.
the end of furlough and cuts in
universal credit could cause a
significant rise in homelessness
according to campaigners the housing
organization crisis says that a lack of
access to broadband will exclude many
people from being able to get support
complaints about noisy neighbours rose
by more than a quarter during lockdown
research out today suggests that more
than a thousand calls were received
every day by councils across the uk last
year at dudley in west midlands saw the
highest number of complaints
sky news has heard allegations that
jehovah's witness elders have failed to
act over child sexual abuse claims in
their church
speaking to alleged victims the claims
range from a failure to report cases to
the police to the demand for high
thresholds of proof from the victims
our home affairs editor jason farrell
reports now on the group that presents a
gentle image on your doorstep
but now faces damaging claims
these children now grown up are speaking
out about an institution they believe to
this day is failing to protect young
people from predatory pedophiles and to
learn from mistakes of the past
emily who doesn't want to be identified
was sexually abused from the age of four
by a ministerial servant of the
jehovah's witnesses in loughborough
aged 8 she reported it to church elders
those in charge of governing and
disciplining the congregation i was very
young and
sort of said i
don't like the way he touches me what
followed was a series of failings that
allowed him to continue sexually abusing
children for years to come which victims
say is a larger cultural problem within
the organization
speaking about jehovah became a
wonderful joy and jehovah's witnesses
have a gentle image of those spreading
the faith but there's a mistrust of
non-believers and it's one of the
reasons why serious allegations such as
child abuse often aren't taken to the
police but instead handled internally
they had a similar kind of meeting with
him about it all and
unbeknownst to me he actually admitted
it to them
and then after that they continued to
tell me that i'd misunderstood it
there was no
kind of reprimand for him i still had to
interact with him i actually got told
off for not sitting on his knee
the abuser peter stewart repented and
said there were no other victims when in
fact there were at least four others
including two sisters who were speaking
out together for the first time because
they believed him he was allowed to
continue in the congregation and my
abuse and my sister's abuse was allowed
to continue
amelia didn't report her abuse until
after peter stewart had been jailed for
abusing two other children
he admitted to it and asked for
forgiveness in this letter to the girl's
mother
when he came out of prison she tried to
stop him rejoining the congregation they
decided that they didn't believe me
because i didn't have a
a credible second witness and because
they have obviously the two witness rule
within the jehovah's witness church yes
the second person has to have seen what
happened they do and it's not just the
two witness rule
the second witness has to be a credible
witness
rachel the elder sister who was abused
first wishes she'd spoken out sooner
i always thought that if i'd have said
that first time if i'd have spoken out
the first time
when he'd kissed me
it wouldn't happen to him
emilia successfully sued the
organization for failing to protect her
there are 130 000 jehovah's witness
members in england and wales with a
large central campus in essex
if elders receive a complaint about
child abuse they will contact the head
office here in chelmsford and they will
consult their legal department as well
as this handbook shepard the flock of
god
only elders can open it and they are all
men with no external child protection
training so what does the book tell them
well it reinforces much of what we've
already heard
eyewitnesses there must be two or three
eyewitnesses not just people repeating
hearsay
no action can be taken if there's only
one witness
lacy jones was abused from the age of 10
for over a decade by an elder in the
west midlands clifford whiteley she has
waived her anonymity to explain what
happened when she told elders at her
kingdom hall in 2019 that she was going
to the police the first thing they said
was it's your absolute right it's your
absolute right to go to the police
however what they don't tell you is that
they will not cooperate cliff had
confessed to the elders and they refused
to hand over that confession to the
police
police eventually got a record of the
confession via a warrant and whiteley
was jailed for nine years in 2020
in a statement the organization said
when elders learn that someone in the
congregation is accused of child sexual
abuse they immediately take steps to
ensure the matter is reported to the
external secular authorities as may be
required by law or if it appears that a
child may be in danger of abuse
elders do not shield a perpetrator from
the legal consequences of his sin do not
interfere with law enforcement and leave
criminal matters to the secular
authorities
any suggestion that jehovah's witnesses
cover up child abuse or in any way
discourage or frown upon reporting
allegations to the secular authorities
is absolutely false
the independent inquiry into child
sexual abuse is due to report its
findings into religious organizations
including jehovah's witnesses later on
whether senior members of the church
will act on them is another matter
jason farrell sky news
more from jason on the website of course
but after the break we will be
discussing the concerns of rising covert
cases as students head back to school
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do they fear they'll be
killed
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside
we know that 800 000 people have been
displaced
i think experiencing the two million
person march in hong kong
that was a moment
[Applause]
[Music]
please have been
tear gas and rubber bullets
you see fires all around us here siobhan
robbins sky news bangkok
[Music]
it was my vision to come and protect old
life in future
[Music]
animals like lion can enter into bomas
they kill their livestocks and this
leads to human wildlife
[Music]
did you know that if we make small
changes to our lives we can reduce air
pollution by loads but how much exactly
loads
high pressure stays with us until the
weekend so the weather stays really
quite quiet the best of the sunshine in
the northwest but uh through the course
of the day we will find the cloud
thinning and breaking to give some
bright or sunny spells temperatures
typically in the mid to late teens but
we could see a high of 24 degrees
celsius over parts of scotland that's 75
degrees fahrenheit now the air remains
fairly clear because we're in this
northeasterly flow but the winds going
round to the east so we could just see
one or two pockets of moderate air
pollution most likely in the south today
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now pupils start to return to classrooms
in england and wales this morning and
what could prove to be a big test for
the government's education policies in
england pupils will now be able to mix
with other year groups face coverings
are optional and contacts of a positive
case will no longer have to isolate
automatically joining us now on the
programme dr ivonne doyle medical
director for public health england dr
dawg great to see you this morning and
then i think plenty to discuss about
how covert 19 may well affect our
schools moving forward but could we just
start with a very general very broad
question i mean how important in your
mind is it that our young peoples very
young all the way up to late teens how
important is it that they get back into
schools and have a proper goal at
face-to-face learning this year
good morning neil it's very important uh
being in education face to face in
person is good for children young people
it's good for their education but that's
actually very good for their health as
well
and if children young people are
unfortunate enough to pick up a coveted
infection it's generally very mild
and it they may not even know they've
got that and we know from our regular
surveys that schools are not the hubs of
infection they reflect what's going on
in the local community but we are causes
we want young people to take two tests
in person on site in the school in the
first week and then twice per week at
home until at least the end of september
just to pick up those late summer
viruses that they may have picked up
elsewhere
and
i i take your point about what happened
what happens in schools reflects what
happens in communities but of course you
know the schools have been closed for
the summer holiday we will have people
mixing together indoors often in not
particularly well ventilated areas i
mean we will see a rise in covid as a
result of this won't we
we're expecting to see more cases
because we'll be testing for that
precisely
neil so we are asking the students to
take these tests and then to do this
throughout september and that is to
protect them and those around them but
also to ensure that there's the minimal
disruption to their education
just in terms of of long covert it was
something we spoke about with the
education sector a little bit earlier on
and it's slightly outside of his brief
but it does have an effect on the
children for whom he has responsibility
perhaps is one in in seven
young people now displaying signs of
of suffering from some form of long
covert months after their initial
infection i mean i i understand the
mortality is not something that younger
people need to worry about but they can
still suffer some pretty significant
effects though
so this is a long covet is the subject
of a lot of study and we still don't
fully understand that and particularly
how long long is in younger people so i
think this is something that is under a
constant review and actually long covert
isn't one
particular disease it's a series of
syndromes and it really does need to be
better understood
can we talk about something which we do
we do know a reasonable amount and that
is that the mental health of our young
people and the negative impact that
being away not just from education but
from their friends has in a social
circumstance social circumstances has
had i mean just in terms of the return
to school
in protecting our young people's mental
health it is of huge significance again
isn't it
very much so and this is part of the the
healthiness of being at school and and
we're very supportive of children being
back at school we would want the school
we always have but particularly now
we're in a different year to last year
many more people are vaccinated 16 to 17
year olds are backs are offered
vaccination and i would encourage them
to accept that and of course the 12 to
15 year olds who are clinically
vulnerable are also offered vaccination
so
this school is the right place to be we
want uh young people now to catch up on
their education
it's good for their mental health it's
good for their physical health neil as
well
and there are a number of measures in
place in schools it's a it's a package
of hygiene uh of cleansing uh
good good ventilation where they're in
enclosed bases the testing is really
important in september and i'd stress
that again and of course the vaccination
offers now if a young person has been in
close contact with a case they will be
offered a pcr test as well and they'll
be provided with advice in order not to
put clinically vulnerable people at risk
so there's a whole package in place here
to try and keep our young people in
education
just one question on variance away from
schools although it may well have have
an effect on schools we're starting to
see some concerns raised about about the
colombian variant i mean how much do we
know
well this is under surveillance all the
time we have a very active genomics
program in the uk we're very connected
to the who so and internationally so the
uk is a net donor on genomics uh to the
world really about surveillance and we
we're watching this very carefully
obviously uh we
will want to ensure that everyone plays
their role in keeping transmission of
the virus low because if that doesn't
happen variants get a better chance of
just developing but the predominant
variant at the moment is still the delta
variant and we know a great deal about
that
we know that the vaccines work pretty
well against it where are you in your
mind about this the strength of the
arguments for vaccinating more than just
the clinically vulnerable in the age
group 12 to 15.
well this is a policy decision first and
foremost but it's also a scientific
discussion that's underway with the
joint committee on vaccination and
immunization that's very topical at the
moment i think we need to leave it to
them they are they will consider very
carefully the balance of risk and
benefit but more groups have been
offered
for the conversation we're having now
young people the 16 to 17 year olds are
now offered vaccination and extremely
clinically vulnerable people will always
be in sight for vaccination
dr evan doyle from public health england
great to see you this morning thanks
very much for your time
thank you
you